[Musique]
depuis des siècles l'exploitation
forestière occupe une place importante
dans l'économie du québec sans surprise
donc l'ajout d'aires protégées sur des
territoires alloué à cette industrie
fait craindre des pertes de revenus et
d'emplois alors comment concilier
économie et protection de la
biodiversité
sur la haute côte nord à sacré-coeur pas
très loin de tadoussac on retrouve les
installations de l'entreprise forestière
bois ça cool
la perte de territoires de coupe au
profit de nouvelles aires protégées y
est accueillie avec réserve on considère
que c'est important d'être prudent dans
la manière de d'envisager s'est approché
de protéger l'eau
pour nous la forêt est une richesse
collective
l'ensemble des activités de bois sakho
en forêt et en usine génère quelque 600
emplois c'est majeur dans une région où
l' indice de vitalité économique est
faible par rapport au reste du québec
considérant le bassin de population
bon ça court comme importance très très
très très grande dans la vie socio
économique du milieu
ici depuis des générations
on gagne sa vie grâce à l'exploitation
de la forêt mon père mon grand père
grands parents arrière grands parents
ont toujours étaient puiserait dans le
secteur forestier dans le fond c'est
notre milieu de vie puis on considère
que quelque part qui que nous soyons
nous dépendons tous de la forêt
que ce soit pour le travail pour les
activités récréatives pour les matériaux
qu'on a besoin pour construire nos
maisons nous dépendons toujours la forêt
sur le territoire québécois on comptait
en 2010
952 municipalité pour lesquels
l'industrie du bois représentait une
force économique majeure ce secteur
d'activité serait directement
responsable de 60 mille emplois à
travers la province
des travailleurs qu'on retrouve en forêt
mais aussi dans le domaine des pâtes et
papiers ou dans la fabrication de
produits en bois
l'ensemble de cette industrie représente
près de 2% du produit intérieur brut du
québec
chez moi ça qu on est persuadé que
l'industrie forestière a toujours sa
place dans le québec de demain
le bois c'est le matériau le plus
écologique c'est celui qui crée le moins
d'émissions de carbone dans sa
production
il faut enlever dans notre esprit
l'aspect que une récolte implique la
disparition de la forêt cette forêt
l'eau revient puis ça se fait avec avec
le cas en tant qu'être humain mais il
faut s'inscrire dans cette dynamique là
qu'on trouve le moyen de bien la
ménagerie de la protéger bien évidemment
des feux des épidémies puis tout en
protégeant bien évidemment la
biodiversité en s'adaptant pour les
différentes espèces qui peuvent être
concernés
voit sa co détient des droits de coupe
sur des territoires situés à l'intérieur
du projet d'aires protégées des innus de
pessamit
la création d'une zone dans le pipe mois
gagnent où il ne serait plus possible de
couper des arbres soulève des craintes
c'est clair que pour nous ça
pourrait engendrer des impacts
importants particulièrement dans notre
territoire d'approvisionnement où il ya
aucune marge de manoeuvre il ya
peut-être des territoires qui peut avoir
plus de marge de manoeuvre nouilles au
plus aucune marge de manoeuvre il ya
personne qu'une mauvaise intention mais
on dirait qu'on est comme dans une vague
où on veut protéger pour protéger pour
qu'on protège pour des bonnes raisons
c'est d'abord et avant tout sur
direction l'est de montréal
une équipe de la société pour la nature
et les parcs est à l'oeuvre au milieu du
fleuve sur les intéressent
les biologistes alain branchereau et
benoît tandem arpente le terrain de ce
qui pourrait bientôt devenir un des plus
grands parcs de la région est
potentiellement une nouvelle aire
protégée ce genre d'opportunité l'eau
qui sont très rares 5.4 km 540 hectares
dans la région de montréal deux temps
public
revenu citoyen au niveau de l'axé nature
il faut absolument tirer avantage de
cette opportunité l'eau dans la
protéger
[Musique]
depuis 30 ans alain branchereau milite
pour la protection de la biodiversité et
la création d'aires protégées au québec
il en a long à dire sur l'influencé
qu'exercerait l'industrie forestière
auprès du ministère des forêts de la
faune et des parcs
quand vient le temps de créer des aires
protégées
notre compréhension et que le lobby de
la foresterie est trop puissant québec
le ministre ces responsables des forêts
de la faune et des parcs est dans une
situation
inconfortable avec deux missions opposée
puis d'un point de vue humain ça doit
pas être facile à gérer cette idée là
d'avoir à satisfaire le lobby forestier
et à remplir sa mission de protection de
la biodiversité au niveau de la forme
c'est juste incompatibles shebwa ce coup
on ne partage pas cet avis est ce que
les compagnies forestières actuellement
bloquent les projets d'aires protégées
au québec on n'a pas l'impression que
les
l'industrie ou quelques autres
intervenants peuvent bloquer sur moi je
pense que le gouvernement
est en position d'avoir des dépressions
différentes sources mais nous on veut
s'assurer que le gouvernement nous
entende aussi ça c'est clair
le gouvernement at-il entendu la voix de
l'industrie si on suit cette ligne noire
elle indique la limite nord du
territoire attribué à l'industrie
forestière on se rend vite compte que
les quelques 80 projets d'aires
protégées rejeté en 2020 se trouvent
presque tous à l'intérieur de cette
vaste zone ces projets d'une superficie
de 22 mille kilomètres carrés aurait
contribué à atteindre la cible de 17 %
de protection des territoires terrestres
et d'eau douce de la province mais ça ne
s'est pas passé comme ça grâce à des
documents internes on apprend que le
ministère de l'environnement semblait
favorable aux projets d'aires protégées
du sud cependant le ministère des forêts
de la faune et des parcs ne voyait pas
les choses de la même manière ils ont
réussi exactement ce qu'ils voulaient y
ont bloqué tous les projets pour
lesquels il y avait un potentiel fort et
si c'est choquant c'est choquant parce
que on a un gouvernement qui de bonne
foi veut atteindre un objectif
s'engagent à atteindre un objectif et là
il ya un joueur dans ton équipe qui joue
contre toi c'est un peu de bon sens
nous avons rencontré les deux ministres
au coeur de ces décisions le portrait
classique on essaye de nous dépeint
souvent on sait le yak quelques gens qui
souvent nous d'acier comme le bunker
c'est sûr que si moi je suis avec ma
vision d'une heure puis que je veux dire
que le ministère unique et fort et je
peux pas les empêcher de le penser mais
je vais vous dire une chose moi je suis
très à l'aise avec la manière qu'on a
travaillé nos dossiers jusqu'à présent
puis je m'excuse pour ceux qui nous
accusent d'être là banker me devrait
venir passer une journée au ministère il
verrait qu'on s'occupe pas mal plus que
je de la foresterie
du côté de l'environnement au maintien
que le ministère a fait ses choix en
toute indépendance je peux pas reprocher
aux fonctionnaires du ministère font de
forêt et parcs de défendre les missions
de leur ministère c'est leur mandat moi
qu'un jeu mon collègue alain fauré story
m6 par benoît ce secteur là pour nous
c'est plusieurs
centaines d'emplois ou c'est un village
à travers ces séries qui a envie je dois
tenir compte parce qu'il faut y habiter
ce territoire-là est l inverse quand moi
je leur dise ce secteur là en terme de
patrimoine naturel et d'une balle arras
inestimable il le considère donc c'est
beaucoup de concertation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dernièrement la mobilisation pour
réclamer davantage d'aires protégées
dans le sud du québec a pris de
l'ampleur tant chez les allochtone que
chez les autochtones
est-ce que c'est ton nom du 49e
parallèle que se concentre la
biodiversité
c'est important de protéger le nord mais
on doit aussi à protéger les territoires
sur l'ensemble du québec du sud jusqu'au
nord
[Applaudissements]
québec a fait un bout de chemin en 2021
le gouvernement a annoncé la protection
des territoires de mach qui qui est de
l'île bizard ainsi que la création de
deux projets pilotes d'aires protégées
d'utilisation durable
un sur l'île d'anticosti et l'autre dans
le secteur du lac à moïse en
collaboration avec la nation huronne
wendat
et puis en février 2022 on a ajouté dix
nouvelles aires protégées dans le sud du
québec d'une superficie de 300
kilomètres carrés ces territoires sont
situés dans les régions de la côte nord
des laurentides de lanaudière et de
l'outaouais
est ce que ça fait bouger les druides
pourcentages sont des roses ou très peu
très très peu pour tout dire parce que
on un vaste territoire un au québec 1%
essentiellement seize mille kilomètres
carrés donc là je vous parle de 300
quelques kilomètres carrés donc on l'a
fait bouger mais à peine ce sont des
superficies cultivées qui sont visées
pour aller chercher une belle
représentativité de la diversité
biologique que l'on retrouve au québec
le statut final de protection des
futures aires protégées demeure encore à
préciser la volonté du gouvernement est
de faire en sorte que ces territoires
soient accessibles à la population
la demande pour cet axe est la nature
est de plus en plus grande pour combres
souhaité que ce ne soit pas dans tous
les codes et cloche de verre où on ne
peut même pas s'y rendre on veut que les
québécois et les québécoises puissent
profiter ce patrimoine naturel là
ce n'est qu'un début promet le ministre
de l'environnement le québec est lié aux
objectifs de la convention sur la
diversité biologique des nations unies
si la nouvelle cible de protection passe
à 30 % du territoire d'ici 2030 il va
s'y conformer le québec est un joueur
important au niveau de la biodiversité
international d'ailleurs le québec au
canada et le premier avoir atteint ses
cibles il faut faire attention on parle
de 30 % de protection ça ne veut pas
dire que ce ne sont que des aires
protégées parce que différentes
possibilités de protection mais si la
communauté internationale tend vers cet
objectif là ça devient drôle objectifs
du québec également
mais comment va-t-on arriver à atteindre
cette cible ambitieuse
d'un côté le ministère des forêts de la
faune et des parcs annonce qu'il va
quasiment doubler la récolte de bois au
québec d'ici 2080 de l'autre il tarde à
mettre en place sa stratégie pour la
sauvegarde du caribou un plan qui va
nécessiter la protection de vastes
territoires en collaboration avec les
premières nations
on se retrouve dans une dynamique
puisque automatiquement les élus doivent
faire partie de la solution puisqu'un
moi j'en entends parler c'est que bois
sakho qui d'un territoire concerné que
vous me parlez travaille en partenariat
avec les unions pour essayer de trouver
les meilleures conditions et la
commission itinérante indépendante qu'on
a mis en place cet assaut qu'elle va
servait à aller publiquement jaser avec
les intervenants se posent les experts
que je veux puis c'est correct les
experts ils nous ont fait part des
problématiques lorsqu'on veut savoir
c'est au niveau social au niveau
économique et au niveau des communautés
autochtones c'est quoi les ans je suis
en fait l action ou telle action c'est
ce qui va nous permettre par la suite de
donner les orientations pour la
stratégie
même si les positions peuvent sembler
irréconciliables il reste encore de
l'espoir pour trouver des solutions
si on ne travaille pas ensemble ci a pas
de volonté politique qu'ils écoutaient
je comprends là on a chacun notre
mission mais en même temps pour arriver
à des résultats concrets on n'y arrive
pas si la grande différence je pense
bien il ya plein de choses possibles
puissent au sort on est ouvert à toute
forme de collaboration plus de
possibilités qui vont permettre de
s'assurer qu'on continue à ménager
correctement la forêt puis de le faire
de la bonne manière mais il faut qu'on
se parle d' avance le comprenez donc
pour succès le lait la preuve
collaborative est fondamental pour nous
on peut pas être dans cette dynamique
inefficace de lutte continuelle pour la
mise en place d'aires protégées
il faut le faire protéger le territoire
c'est le geste politique le plus
stratégique actuellement
[Musique]
bon